what if I told you that an underground
city bigger than Manhattan existed in
the United States and not just any
underground city a city that hosts
meetings for the Illuminati secret
government agencies billionaires and
even lizard people this is the Denver
International Airport is it true that
there's an entire city under this
Airport what makes people think this
exists and could an underground city be
possible this is what if and here's what
would happen if there were an
underground city below Denver
International Airport the Denver
International Airport or dia for short
was finished in 1995
since then forums on the internet have
been littered with conspiracy theories
ranging from an entire underground city
to Nazi meetings depending on how you
want to look at it the DIA can be seen
as anything but a regular airport the
first aspect that stands out is its
enormous size it's the fifth busiest
airport in North America and also the
largest at 137 square kilometers hmm
that's almost big enough to have a small
city underneath it but that's not all
inside the airport is a dedication stone
that uses symbols from the Freemasons an
old secret society then there are the
runways from above they may look to be
oddly shaped and if you take a closer
look you might see something else some
believe that these runways are laid out
like swastikas
and below the runways are massive
underground tunnels these tunnels are
just kind of there without any real
explanation for why they might exist
construction of the airport went over
budget by two billion yeah billion
dollars now what was all that money used
for maybe some of it was used for the
talking gargoyles scattered about the
airport or that massive horse statue
outside of it yeah creepy and on top of
all this wouldn't an airport be a
perfect place for secret society members
from all around the world to come and
gather hmm this is starting to sound
kind of plausible well if any of this is
true and there is an underground city
where secret meetings take place how
could this change the world
well the biggest implication would be if
there were a fully functioning
underground city this large to put the
size of this in perspective the city
under DIA would be about 15 and a half
kilometers bigger than San Francisco now
assuming that this underground city has
access to food water a way to get
sunlight and electricity yet people
would have no problem living here and an
underground city like this might be a
good place for a humans to live in in
the future
someday Earth's surface might become
inhospitable for humans this would mean
we might need to start living
underground and what better place for
Americans to start than underneath the
Denver International Airport its massive
and we could assume that the
infrastructure would be good enough for
people to call home considering that
this thing was supposedly built for
billionaires
and speaking of which what secret
meetings are supposed to be taking place
there now
well these secret society meetings would
be about everything from how these
people can make more money to how they
can further control the world but
they'll never let us know they exist and
besides maybe having us
speculating about them is all a part of
their secret strategy of hiding in plain
sight so this all sounds pretty
plausible but is any of it really true
as fun as talking about this conspiracy
might be I hate to break it to you but
no there isn't a city under Denver's
Airport and there are no secret meetings
either all these theories are just
speculation they don't hold any water
sure you can trace the outline of a
swastika on the runways but that ignores
the fact that there's another leg on the
runway and it's not symmetrical at all
the reason why it's so big is that when
the airport was built they wanted to
keep it far away from residential areas
and they wanted more space available to
expand the airport if they needed to do
so and the underground bunkers well
those were initially intended for an
automated baggage system but due to the
prohibitive cost it was never finished
that's also most likely why the airport
went so far over budget and as for the
art yeah sure it's creepy but it's just
that some weird creepy art it's not
meant to be a symbol of a secret society
it's just something for passengers to
look at as they move through the airport
it's safe to say there isn't an
underground city under the Denver
International Airport but what if
instead of there just being an
underground city humanity had to live
underground permanently well we'll leave
that story for another what-if
[Music]